[Musique]
euh, nous soutenons le magasin qui se
prépare pour les élections,
nous ne savons pas ce qui pourrait arriver, donc l'
histoire se prépare à
casser des émeutes, tout ça,
nous avons eu deux émeutes de pillage et
la première fois que nous avons été touchés, alors nous  nous devons
nous protéger
probablement euh peut se reproduire pour l'
élection ou avant l'élection ou après
l'élection
euh il y a beaucoup d'énergie autour de cette
élection il y a beaucoup de gens qui sont
très excités de voter
que ce soit de l'infirmière de fret de
cobid  de certaines des
manifestations raciales pour la justice raciale du début de cette année
et de la nature de cette élection et
des candidats impliqués,
je pense qu'il y a plus d'attention non
seulement dans cette élection, mais aussi cette année
en général,
j'ai des appréhensions, j'espère que non,
mais s'il y a un  manifestation j'espère que
c'est une manifestation pacifique parce que les gens ont
le droit de le faire
selon la constitution cela ne
vous sert à rien de venir casser
des vitres
voler dans les magasins ou quoi que ce soit
je suis vraiment inquiet de la façon
dont les émotions exacerbées des gens
vont avoir un impact sur
la ville après les élections et je
comprends pourquoi les magasins et les restaurants
embarquent, j'espère que cela n'arrivera pas
à cela, mais j'ai aussi
donné toutes les émotions et
la violence accrues que nous avons vues cet été,
euh, je le pense  il est logique que les gens
aient peur